c'est quelque chose de vraiment
extrêmement intéressant on a eu en début
d'année les nouveaux smartphones de
samsung c'était les samsung galaxy s 20
elle devint plus s20 ultra et on a eu la
gamme note il ya pas longtemps il ya eu
plein de produits sortis durant l'année
donc ça c'est plutôt normal on suit un
calendrier assez normal et là ils nous
sortent au moins de septembre 2020 un
nouveau samsung galaxy 20-f efe pour
fans edition alors c'est vachement
intéressant de se dire pourquoi est ce
que samsung vient se positionner avec un
smartphone à moins de 700 euros on et
vous savez dans l'idée tarifaire de ce
qu'on appelle en tout cas le flagship
qui leur à quelque chose près d'une
nouvelle proposition qui est extrêmement
intéressante côté de chez samsung sur la
gamme f
vint alors je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez il a gagné on a vu déjà le s10
eux on a vu le s10 lite on oublie tout
ces dénominations on arrive sur une
nouvelle dénomination parce que tout en
recherche derrière qui a été fait en
marketing pour trouver effectivement le
nom qui correspondrait le mieux aux
attentes des consommateurs on a donc un
nouveau smartphone qui est plutôt cool
qui a une bonne fiche technique et qui
raconte vraiment pas de belles histoires
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec poulpe et ou
alors je sais pas si vous connaissez
poulpeo poulpeo c'est un service de
cashback sa service qui va vous
permettre de faire rembourser une partie
des achats que vous allez faire sur
internet
si vous ne connaissez pas je vous laisse
imaginer les trucs vous êtes sur
internet je sais pas moi vous allez par
exemple surbooking vous allez sur asos
et vous vous dites je veux faire mes
achats vous activez votre cash back
poulpeo vous faites vos achats
normalement sur votre site et à la fin
on vous rembourse une partie de vos
achats
une partie de l'argent que vous avez
dépensé vous revient c'est quand même
dommage de s'en priver
le système est très simple poulpeo est
commissionné par les boutiques sur
lequel vous allez faire vos achats les
boutiques partenaires et vous rétrocède
une partie de la commission autant dire
que c'est gratuit c'est malin ça vous
coûte absolument rien et en plus vous
récupérer de l'argent sans vos achats
personnellement j'utilise le service
depuis un petit moment et je puis vous
assurer que les gars sont là
ici c'est le montant qu'on peut virer
126 euros 63
ici j'ai le total de mes économiques
correspondent à 4 122 98 et s'il ya les
différentes catégories mode femme mode
homme enfant high tech électroménager
bien-être beauté voyager location sport
mais en jardin alimentation et 20
loisirs et culture il ya beaucoup de
choses j'ai beaucoup de remous
nous ce qui nous intéresse beaucoup et
bien voyez c'est high tech et
électroménager voyez notamment chez acer
vous avez 2 25% de cash back chez darty
2% chez dyson 2 % et chez samsung
vous avez 7 % au lieu des 3,6 pouces
actuels ce qui fait que si vous achetez
votre samsung galaxy s 20-f feu et bien
vous allez récupérer 7 % du montant de
votre achat en cash back directement
dans votre compte poulpeo et ça c'est
vachement bien pour activer votre cash
back c'est très facile vous cliquez ici
sur activer le cashback activation en
cours samsung cashback activé et
maintenant vous pouvez y aller go c'est
parti ça vous emmène sur le site de
samsung
vous n'avez plus qu'à faire vos achats
et vous récupérez 7% de la somme fait si
vous descendez tout en bas vous allez
voir plus que vous pouvez activer votre
cash back en un clic grâce à l'assistant
poulpeo vous ajoutez votre extension
directement à votre navigateur et quand
vous arrivez sur un site partenaire et
bien ça bien vous le stipulait je vois
ici ma petite partie poulpeo je n'ai
montant de cash back qui sont affichés
34,34 euros de cash back activé et gk
faire mes achats directement en ligne ça
c'est cool
les voiliers en plus j'ai une
application que je peux venir installer
ios android pour activer votre cash back
très facilement lorsque vous faites vos
achats depuis votre mobile
question pratique c'est que dès que vous
avez 10 euros disponible dans votre
cagnotte
vous pouvez demander un virement tout
récupérer l'argent dont vous dire c'est
cool c'est pratique et d'ailleurs il ya
un jeu concours vous pouvez gagner 100
euros en carte d'achat grâce à poulpeo
il suffit de venir vous inscrire
directement ce site de poulpeo vous
cliquer sur je suis parrainer vous
rentrez le code greu 2020 je vous ai
tous remis en bas dans la description
déjà que de les récupérer 5 euros au
lieu de 3 euros en guise de bienvenue ça
c'est cool et en plus des vous aurez
fait votre premier achat de cash back et
bien vous serez éligible pour gagner la
carte cadeau de son oeuvre
je vous donnerai résultats dans le
courant de novembre ça vous laisse le
temps à vos achats tranquille loin de
trouver le produit qui vous intéresse et
pensez avoir le réflexe poulpeo je la
chante le prendre non en avant-première
à l'heure où je dois faire un tour un
petit peu complet pour voir à quoi ils
ressemblent et la fiche technique et on
sera le test des sites quelques jours
d'ailleurs je vous invite à venir vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
comme ça vous saurez tout quand je vous
en parlerai ça c'est cool
il ya un design cas c'est intéressant
enfin de voiliers à la différence d'un
écran incurvé confrères trouvait
notamment le samsung galaxy s 20 du
début d'année là on a un écran qui est
tout plat on a néanmoins d'écran
dynamiques amoled avec une résolution
full hd plus de 1400 par mille 800
pixels à 405 pixels par pouces un écran
avec un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz donc on reste vraiment dans le
haut du panier
par rapport à ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
perdre écran qui a bien lutté contre la
lumière bleue on dessine une diagonale
de 6 5 pouces qui a une taille qui situe
entre le s20 et le s20 plus ok donc là
on est chez samsung avec william frey à
des coûts très bien toi et toi ça va
vite accueillir à nouveau d'un exercice
13 devrait devenir le regarde et on met
nos distances on a nos masques on est
loin d'un autre c'est vachement bien les
ultras temps en temps comme ça qu'on
pourra filmer alors c'est un nouveau
dans la gamme et les vins c'est le s20
ffe fans edition c'est ça alors au lieu
de parler de tout ce qui va être spect
pour lui je me suis dit comprendre le
positionnement fait et le pourquoi du
comment parce qu'on avait l'habitude de
voir l'année dernière et ce 10e et se
disent light et là on a un changement
non avec f
fall edition tout à fait toutes les
explications il ya un pourquoi du
comment et quelque chose où l'on sait
pas trop oui j'ai une explication alors
comme comme tu le sais on la gamme s et
la famille est chez nous qui sur le clos
de gamme et la famille à qui est
vraiment sur le milieu de gamme
ouais
à des prix généralement tout 500 euros
prix public conseillé cette année on a
le s20 et feu qui vient compléter la
famille 20 à l'entrée de famille devant
et qui va se dresser un public un peu
plus large
d'où le nom fans edition avec ses
nombreuses couleurs notamment on va
trouver un capteur d'empreintes
digitales
sous l'écran on a une certification ip68
le gros point fort de la gamme s pour le
s20 c'est la photo est ici au garde ce
qui fonctionne
on a un grand angle de 12 mégapixels
ouvre à f 1.8 on a un ultra grand-angle
de 12 mégapixels couvre f 2.2 on avait
l'objectif de 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.4 avec un zoom optique x 4 et le space
zoom x 30
alors ça on verra effectivement lors du
test d'ici quelques jours à la
différence du s1 on n'a pas un 64
mégapixels au niveau du téléobjectif
mais ça me paraît normal qu est ce qu
une fois de plus on est sur une fiche
technique et quand même réduite même si
on regarde vraiment ce qui fonctionne
dans cette gamme s20 le mode single take
est toujours là vous pouvez filmer en 4k
jusqu'à 60 fps
ici pas de lui qu'à mais est-ce qu'on a
réellement besoin a vous de me le dire
en bas en commentaire à l'avant on a une
caméra de celle fille de 30 2 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f 2.2 contre une caméra de
10 mégapixels ou pour le samsung galaxy
s dans intéressant qu'un var vient là
ceci jusque là bien là là là tu es de
retour
il faut dire aux gens que moment bah oui
que tu es la plus aisée pas me toucher
la mort alors tu sais moi je trouve
toujours une question barbara ouest et à
regarder harry potter depuis qu'on en
parle et sa fille a longtemps mais j'ai
profité pour j'aime avoir un regard des
fruits harry potter tout à l'heure tu
veux savoir c'est que barbara le travail
fait samsung n'a absolument jamais
regarder harry potter c'est quand même
la loose
c'est vite dit fois jamais vu harry
potter au tourne toujours sur ou annuel
pas de surprise là dessus mais là où
vient la surprise ses côtés performances
avec le processeur vous avez 2 confie
différentes souvenez vous je vous
retrace un petit peu l'histoire sur le
haut de gamme de samsung soit la gamme
no to la gamme s vous avez deux versions
une version amérique du nord avec le
possesseur de qualcomm le plus haut de
gan ici notamment c'est le stand dragon
865 et pour le reste du monde vous avez
le processeur de 5
tin exynos 990 qui marche bien mais
qu'il sera moins performant que le stand
ragone 865 la gestion de l'énergie est
un peu moins bonne et là c'est vachement
intéressant parce que vous avez deux
versants vous avez une version 4g est
une version 5 g alors ça on l'avait déjà
avec les samsung galaxy s 20 et s20 plus
on avait une version 4g une version 5 g
mais dans les deux cas on avait le
processeur de samsung exynos 990 ici
samsung reprend un peu sa copie et vous
laisse le choix
vous avez le choix entre la version 4g
un exynos 990 et la version 5 g un stade
ragon 865 et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que si vous prenez un
smartphone 4g vous aurez un smartphone
qui marchera bien l'exynos 990 i
performant fonctionne bien mais vous
n'allez pas avoir le haut du panier vous
avez pas voir ce qui se fait de mieux
si vous voulez ce qui se fait de mieux
il faut partir sur la version 5 g avec
le dragon 865 ça veut dire que si vous
voulez vraiment de la performance et que
vous vous en fichez de la saq j ai bien
il faut acheter un smartphone 5 g qui
vous coûtera 100 euros plus cher pour le
prix je donne dans quelques instants
vous voyez cette réflexion est
intéressante parce que on voit un virage
qui s'opèrent du côté de samsung dans le
choix de ses processeurs là vous avez
choix entre deux modèles
allez savoir si des bus de ville 21 au
niveau des samsung galaxy s 30
est-ce qu'on n'aura pas uniquement un
processeur qualcomm wait and see moi ce
qui m'intéresse là dedans c'est vraiment
de comprendre pourquoi est ce que
samsung va nous sortir aujourd'hui un
produit
fanelli shon c'est une dénomination
qu'on n'avait pas l'habitude de voir
pourquoi c'est quoi l'idée en fait alors
l'idée c'est que en fait après la partie
du s dans comme à faire partie de
produits il ya de nombreuses études qui
ont été menées par notre siège sur ce
qui a plu sur ce qui n'a pas plu ce qui
est sûr ce qui est demandé sur cette
famille puisqu'il était dans l'est dans
les clous de sortir un produit et ce vin
sur la fin d'année
bondues les du coût au siège encore et
on s'est dit comment allait proposer un
produit qui convient encore plus à une
grande palette d'utilisateurs et
différentes choses ont été demandés
comme les différentes couleurs comme
d'avoir enfin de conserver les choses
qui font l'adn du s20 donc la photo
évidemment puisqu'on et on prend
vraiment l'héritage photo du s2
réduisant plus ne pourra voir le fond
entre processeur exynos qu'on avait déjà
sur les rangs mais aussi ce dernier stop
argonne 865 c'est surtout un truc qui le
souhaitent ses singles c'est nouveau ça
chez samsung on sait que notamment sur
les gammes avec i'm not gabès tard les
versions us canada est encore une autre
région où tu va se retrouver avec le
stand rigolo 865 plus haut de gamme de
qualcomm et pour l'europe parce que du
monde je veux dire pas l'exil aux 590 là
sur le même modèle sur le même marché
entre une version kajiya soit 5,6 on n'a
pas eu le même processeur ouais c'est
justement une des choses qui avaient été
remontés remonté par l'utilisateur
on le voit aussi dans dans les vidéos
comme et tiendront dans les commentaires
c'est du matos qui remonte et du coup de
choix a été fait mais sur cette fin
d'année pour l'europe d'aller proposer
une variante avec le modèle le modèle
standard gones pour ceux qui le
souhaitent les skis vachement
intéressant là dedans c'est qu'en fait
pour 100 euros des cartes une petite
pause de la question de prendre la 4g la
5g
mais pour 100 euros des cas tu te poses
la question d'avoir un smartphone qui
veulent un peu plus performant et avec
une meilleure gestion de l'autonomie qui
nous disons qu'à chaque fois nous notre
adn c'est vraiment de proposer plus de
choix possible à l'utilisateur
oui donc là tu vas voir pour voir des
fois entre la 4g la 5g entre le 128 et
256 go mais aussi entre deux processeurs
donc chacun trouvera vraiment ce qui lui
convient mieux là c'est une offre à
tiroirs qui se compliquent un peu quoi
qui se complique mais bath à des dons ça
dépend toujours de quelle manière on
voit la chose ça peut se compliquer
méchas numéro 4 i fait intéressant pour
celui qui ne veut pas être bloqués
trouver quelqu'un qui est vraiment
technophiles et qui est vraiment sur le
côté pointu de la performance et qui
veulent lire je pars sur le snapdragon
vous à quelqu'un qui va se dire écoute -
version 4g il va très bien et l'exil
hausse de 5,3 par rapport à mai aux usa
japon qui correspondra et je préfère
économiser un type au niveau des
critiques après je vais aussi rassurer
les utilisateurs avec les hits l'exil
990 marche très bien le faire enfin tous
on veut sur un terrain bien il marche
très bien après c'est vrai que pour ce
qui valait peut-être aller un peu plus
loin ou qui ont lu les différents tests
qui sont parues ce point qui nourrit
khimki son pari cette année ils auront
le choix de s'orienter vers cette
d'argonne mais c'est une question
technophiles un clermont talonne
clairement sur la version 4g vous avez
si giga de ram c'est la lpddr2 5 au
niveau de la version 5 g vous avez 8
gigas de ram c'est une fois de plus de
la levée dès 10h05
vous avez soit 128 soit 256 go de
stockage dans les deux cas extensible
grâce à une carte microsd jusqu'à 1 kg à
l'are et ça c'est cool et vous avez une
grosse batterie de 4500 milliampères
heures avec de la recharge rapide 25
watts de la recharge sans fil 15 watts
et de la recherche inversée pour venir
charger votre montre vos buzz et
compagnie ça c'est bien aussi vous avez
soit une double sim soit une manne
hocine plus une carte microsd pour
l'extension ça je voulais vie vous avez
du bluetooth 5.0 vous avez du wifi si
vous avez du nfc
enfin on a une fiche technique est hyper
robuste pour un smartphone qui est hyper
intéressant pourquoi est ce que j'irai
acheter ce smartphone là plutôt qu'un
galaxy à 71 par exemple un emprunt la
partie photo qui est quand même au
dessus puisque sera prof
ll est quasiment identique par l'avicca
a salué ce bien légal pixels à celle du
s devant l'écran qui en sont vertes
voyes la dynamique amoled on va avoir un
produit qui est résistant à l'eau et à
la poussière
nous notre cas de la charge sans fil
ouais c'est important aussi voilà on l'a
pas dit tout à l'heure mais il ya de la
charge sans fil il ya beaucoup davantage
en fait il ya beaucoup d'avantagés à une
version 250 gigas qui peut exister et
aux derniers processeurs beaucoup de
chose qui différencie le plus petit ds
avec ok super et que je te remercie
beaucoup
williams avec plaisir trégor à plusieurs
de t'accueillir plein de rancoeur chez
moi ici
côté tarifs je vous dis tout j'ai tout
noter ici sur la version 128 jia de
stockage khadjimba et à 659 euros un
tarif qui est extrêmement bien placé
pour une gamme s 20 avec ce processeur
avec ce que vous avez derrière et avec
la config photo une fois de plus on sera
le test d'ici quelques jours on a une
version 256 go de stockage 4g toujours
ici on passe à 729 euros vous avez une
version 128 go de stockage en 5 g à 759
euros
et si vous voulez le 256 go de stockage
105g vous êtes à 829 euros et pour les
version 256 vous avez les coloris bleu
blanc rouge y voyez vous avez plein de
couleurs et ça c'est un peu aussi la
nouveauté c'est cette gamme de couleurs
qui est extrêmement étendue
probablement pour venir chercher un
public jeune qui veut des tons colorés
qui va un truc un peu plus punchy ramené
du pex et je trouve ça vraiment très
jolie en plus si vous venez d'acheter
vous avez 4 - de youtube premium offert
six mois de spotify premium et en plus
vous est compatible avec le game passe
de microsoft xbox et vous avez trois
mois offert lorsque vous achetez la
manette comme un smartphone qui est très
intéressant qui vient compléter cette
gamme sans la complexifier on n'a pas le
terme light qui donne un côté pas un peu
cheap mais voyez light l'impression que
moi il ya un côté qui n'est pas terrible
f le fan edition pourquoi pas je ne sais
pas si vous êtes fans et si vous allez
l'est d'ailleurs marqué le mois en bas
en commentaire à ce qui pourrait vous
intéresser ce smartphone moi ce que je
trouve extrêmement intéressant déjà
c'est que samsung garde la base de ces
galaxies 20 avec un super produit avec
une config photo qui est extrêmement
alléchante et surtout qu'ils viennent
chercher un certain dragon 865
aujourd'hui en europe version 5 j'ai
bien évidemment mais malgré tout c'est
très cool mais la question se pose du
petit delta 200 euros même 600 euros ça
reste quand même beaucoup d'argent quand
la version 4g la version 5 g pour avoir
ce qui se fait de mieux en terme de
performance tout ça on en reparlera
d'ici quelques jours mais candidement
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire et quant à nous on donne
rendez vous extrêmement rapidement parce
que vous le savez latex ne s'arrête
jamais des bisous charles chao
[Musique]